- [Narrator] Mitchell
Kriegman created the show
Clarissa Explains It All.
- Yeah, I did.
- [Narrator] And some other classics.
- Yeah, I created Bear
In The Big Blue House,
and I worked on Rugrats, Ren And Stimpy,
Doug, Rocko.
- [Narrator] But, I love
Clarissa, so we came out here
to talk about it,
and learn some things about
the show that we probably
didn't know.
- Cool.
- [Narrator] Here we go.
- The ladder was, I
think, about four rungs,
or something like that.
It was like about maybe this high,
and Sam had to crouch
down underneath the window
and go like a mime, you know,
coming up every time,
and he had to slam it on there,
we had to get that guitar
sting in, of course,
and when they built the set
you could see in the pilot,
we eventually fixed this, right?
In the pilot, you can
see through the window
and see the floor of the studio.
I banned purple, I would
never give a reason,
and I kinda rationalized
it a little bit by saying,
yeah I'm trying to
appeal to boys and girls,
and I said, well it's gotta
be all pink and blue,
you know, we gotta use
those as our main colors,
and purple throws that off.
Bullshit, you know,
complete bullshit, right?
They just ignored me after a while.
Well, I can't really tell
you is the problem with that,
and I've never told anybody, even Melissa.
I had the most amazing writers.
I had Suzanne Collins
who wrote Hunger Games,
Alexa Junge, who was was one
of the main writers on Friends,
Neena Beber wrote plays and wrote Daria.
I mean, these writers, you know,
all went on to do like
amazing stuff, you know?
If you're like 26 to 36, you know,
almost universally, if I say I created
Clarissa Explains It All,
they scream like a 14 year old girl,
and they say that's my childhood,
you made my childhood,
and those are the words everybody says.
It's like my career is 30
years younger than I am,
you know, which I love.
It's super satisfying,
it's completely wonderful.
♫ Just do it ♫